I first meetings intend chugging her
fired
chug start at the beginning
I want to find my son but that wouldn't
tell me who adopted him
there are lizards wearing human skins
and taking over the government they
threatened my wife if I blow the whistle
but their products are making people
sick someone's trying to kill me because
I have powers but they haven't caught up
to me yet thanks to my SuperSpeed I want
to meet my son before I die I need more
proof before I come forward you have to
stop the dinosaur people they already
got jay-z my superhero name the kids in
school used to call me the Whizzer I bet
they did I want you to take a lap around
the block all time I can only speed when
I'm scared
I'm a fear-based hero sorry whether
there is a Quinn jet approaching in our
wakandan contingent is a reporting the
remaining Avengers must have survived
divert them to Washington I want them to
witness this
well at least we know their Scrolls
right hey everybody it's Charlie your
friendly neighborhood Jessica Jones
dropping all kinds of Avengers Easter
eggs so this is only gonna be for the
first episode just careful for spoilers
if you haven't seen it yet but because
these are just Easter eggs they're not
necessarily spoiling anything big from
the series so no worries if you're
finding me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos there's
gonna be a bunch more marvel and
infinity washed up posting in the next
couple of days too so there's really
like a couple of different things going
on here there's some Secret Invasion
there's some Quicksilver and then
there's the Spider Man stuff which sort
of tangentially ties in with Secret
Invasion because of what happened with
those characters in the comics but given
the current state of politics in the
United States right now they probably
drop one of the most meta Easter eggs
ever so this is in the same breath
trying to make fun of the current US
government it also tipped the hat to
Scrolls lizards wearing human skins so
in the comics there were a couple really
big comic arcs one right after the other
starting with civil war in superhero
Registration sokovia accords so what
happened in the wake of that is it
destabilized the entire world leaving it
ripe for invasion from the scrolls which
were just biding their time
impersonating the heroes so you wind up
with all kinds of heroes running around
and you don't know who you can trust
because some of them might secretly be
Scrolls one of them was Jessica Jones
she was actually a scroll during Secret
Invasion but it was one who was wearing
her classic jewel Avengers costume from
back when she was on the original
Avengers team the whole thing about
Civil War is that she had been married
to Luke Cage they'd had their baby girl
Danielle who actually eventually would
go on to become the new Captain America
when she was old enough the whole funny
joke about that is that she had luke
cage's unbreakable skin and super
strength so she would joke about the
fact that she didn't even need the
shield like she herself her body was the
shield because she's so unbreakable you
can't borrow me you can't blast me
and you definitely can't break me I
ain't know but Jessica Jones at Luke
Cage have a big falling out over
superhero registration during civil war
so she bails joins the New Avengers and
starts living at dr. Strange's sanctum
sanctorum then later Secret Invasion
happens she's reunited with Luke Cage
their baby gets stolen by a scroll
that's impersonating Jarvis remember in
the comics Jarvis is an actual person
he's not just an AI like he is in the
movies Norman Osborn helps them rescue
that baby then eventually because Peter
Parker is also one of the New Avengers
during the Dark Reign storyline he
reveals his identity to them and Jessica
finds out that a person she used to go
to high school with has been spider-man
this whole time because every once in a
while during season one and season two
of Jessica Jones they make little
spider-man references because in the
comics they both went to Midtown high so
you got detention you screwed up you
know what you did was wrong the question
is how are you gonna make things right
maybe you were trying to be cool
but take it from a guy who's been frozen
for 65 years the only way to really be
cool to follow the rule so in the comics
spider-man knew Jessica Jones before she
got her powers after that big accident
that killed her family so obviously
season two Jessica Jones is all about
addressing that but in the comics
there's just a much closer association
between those two characters as you guys
probably know the MCU version of the
scrolls are gonna be introduced for the
first time during the Captain Marvel
movie now that's set back during the 90s
sort of laying groundwork for future
Secret Invasion storylines if they want
to do them they haven't confirmed any of
that but I wouldn't be surprised if they
work in the idea that at least one
character that we've been seeing this
whole time turns out to be a scroll but
that's not something that I expect to
get any kind of teasers for until we get
to the Captain Marvel movie and that's
not gonna be till next year
so the Quicksilver Wizard joke is the
whole idea is that he have SuperSpeed
obviously it's a big part of the series
so I don't want to get into too big of
spoilers about how his character is tied
to the Jessica Jones character within
the context of the series but he's just
sort of a discount version of
Quicksilver that crossed paths with them
and eventually was killed in the comics
he's just a really minor character
she's someone for the TV show they
wanted to use in a really funny
interesting way so I know a lot of you
have asked is Quicksilver gonna come
back
during the Avengers films I'd be like
this is about as close as we're gonna
get to real Quicksilver on screen
because there's already way too many
characters during infinity war for them
to cram Quicksilver in would just be
weird like it would have to be a vision
or a memory The Scarlet Witch has of him
some sort of illusion that doesn't
completely roll back her entire
character arc because a lot of where she
is now is because of the death of her
brother
so she's grown a lot as a person to
bring him back would be like bringing
Coulson back it would completely
undercut the whole purpose of their
death so if you guys didn't see it I
actually just posted a video explaining
Thanos's new back story during infinity
war they've changed some of the Infinity
Gauntlet story the reason why he wants
to assemble the gauntlet and why he
wants to change the universe and
unsurprisingly it actually does a really
cool job of turning a really cool moment
from an earlier film and guardians of
the galaxy into a much bigger part of a
Knossos backstory
during infinity war he stones it seems
can only be brandished by things of
extraordinary strength observe these
couriers can use the stone to mow down
entire civilizations like wheat
so think about Isan the searcher the
celestial destroying that planet with
the power gem Antanas being upset about
the death of his people when you watch
that infinity war video that I just
posted it sort of the same thing that
Kevin Feige did when spider-man
homecoming happen and then retroactively
Lee they turned this Iron Man to little
kid into Peter Parker like oh yeah even
though we didn't think that we would
ever get the spider-man character we're
gonna say now retroactively Lee that kid
was Peter Parker dressed up as Iron Man
being inspired by all this crazy stuff
that was going on so long ago but what
will happen is is in the next couple of
days I'll post my non-spoilery review of
the entire season of Jessica Jones and
then obviously there's a whole bunch of
new infinity war coming soon too
so click here for that brand-new
infinity war preview and learn about
Thanos's new backstory and click here
for more Avengers infinity war promos
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight